to get hot I got a lot of I got hairy
legs that turned that that that that
that that that that turn uh
um blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach in the pool and rub
my leg down so it was traded and then
watched the hair come back up again
they'd look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and I've Loved kids jumping on my lap
thank you
ladies and gentlemen is the elderly man
pretending to be president who will be
giving the State of the Union speech
tonight I in contrast I'm Dave Rubin
today is February 7th 2023. this is the
Reuben report as always we are doing a
live post-game show on locals if you'd
like to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and yes the
State of the Union
is tonight and regardless of what the
reality of the State of the Union is uh
you can be assured that the people who
will hand him the paper that he will
read poorly from will write something to
the effect of the State of the Union is
strong and all of the people will
applaud and then everyone will leave and
they'll go eat their fancy meals and
they'll laugh at us as they take more of
our tax money and figure out new ways to
censor us and tank the economy and get
us into Wars and a whole bunch of other
stuff now obviously because the state of
the union is tonight will focus on the
clips and everything else tomorrow but I
did get this is Incredible video this is
really wild video we found video I was
sent this video but I can't even say who
I was saying by because this is serious
stuff somebody sent me this video of how
they prepare Joe Biden for the big talk
tonight and when you watch this you may
note that they're not going to actually
say his name they say another name and
that's because they use an alias
obviously at The Institute anyway this
is Wild video we just got this you guys
are seeing this for the first time this
is incredible undergoes a series of
Medical Treatments designed to cheat
deaths for another week first Mr Burns
chiropractors perform a slight spinal
adjustment
then a team of doctors and ministers eye
drops
painkillers
and a vocal cord scraping don't worry
you won't feel a thing till I Jam this
down your throat
the whole ordeal leads Mr Burns twisted
and disoriented
[Music]
it was when he gave me gave me money but
honestly guys I'm not sure that's that
far off from what they really do to Joe
Biden like you know they inject him with
stuff you know he's got to take some
pills like remember during one of the
debates which one very early on in the
Democrat debates when his eyeball just
exploded and there was just blood
filling up his eye like whatever they
put him on for these things somehow to
the credit of the doctors it gets him
through these things but whatever we
shall see what happens tonight so we're
not going to focus too much uh on that
tonight a little bit of sort of what
he'll be talking about towards the end
of the show but really what I wanted to
focus on today was there is some more
crazy stuff going on in Canada and I
know anytime I talk about Canada on the
show or just in Trudeau specifically we
we get just a crazy amount of email and
comments and messages from Canadians who
are so appreciative that somebody in the
United States is talking about the
craziness in Canada whether it was the
Draconian lockdowns or whether it was
the way that the government Trudeau's
liberal government treated the truckers
and the protesters and that whole thing
or just anything we do on Canada related
to free speech because Canada was once a
great western nation and it is I would
say Hanging On by a very tenuous thread
uh and the policies that Justin Trudeau
is pushing in Canada are the same
policies that I think we're going to see
more and more of in the west fortunately
we here in the United States still have
the First Amendment which is protecting
us but you will see it's not just Justin
Trudeau and it's not just you know some
Bad actors in New Zealand or in
Australia it's that the United Nation uh
United Nations wants to crack down on
free speech and much more so I want to
start here with a video explaining what
bill c-11 is in Canada this is from a
Canada Outlet known as Canada proud they
do a dissection of this bill c-11 which
has just passed the Canadian Senate and
man if you you don't think this is
chilling then I recommend you turn the
channel and go watch The View
Trudeau's censorship dreams just got one
step close to her becoming reality on
Thursday night his internet censorship
bill c-11 past the Senate and has been
sent back to the House of Commons for
final approval what does it mean for you
if this passes it means the Trudeau
government gets to manipulate your
social media algorithms it means they
get to decide what you see online on
Facebook Twitter Instagram Tick Tock
Spotify you name it the bill is
ostensibly designed to protect Canadian
content creators and content creators
don't seem to want it prominent
YouTubers artists and even writers like
Margaret Atwood have all spoken out
against his online censorship regime so
what does this bill actually meant for
if the content creators it's supposed to
protect you don't want it simple it's
meant to control what you see your
algorithms will all be manipulated so
that you only see what the Trudeau
liberals want you to see no more
interesting foreign documentaries for
you only boring Trudeau approved
Canadian content promoting the values
and interests of the liberal party
this dangerous bill must be stopped
freedom of speech and expression is a
fundamental Canadian value and the
creepy control freaks in Trudeau's
Liberal Party have no right to take it
away Canadians should have the right to
read and watch whatever they want online
certainly shouldn't be Justin Trudeau's
job to decide if you agree share this
video okay so you must understand that
C11 has already passed in the Senate now
obviously some of uh the way that video
was framed was was a bit heavy-handed in
terms of what could happen in the future
but does anything surprise you guys at
this point the idea that the government
that the Canadian government in this
case is going to control more of the
internet well certainly it shouldn't
surprise you but it's it's a direct
extension of everything that Justin
Trudeau has been about from day one he
came in with his gay affect and his nice
socks and he became the most
authoritarian leader in the history of
Canada the fact that Canada right now
you know Canada's main broadcaster is
the CBC so they get state-funded news
already that's how the Liberals maintain
control and then they're always going
after the independent journalist outfits
like Rebel TV Rebel TV you guys know
from Ezra Levan and Abby yemeni a bunch
of guys who went over to the World
economic forum and did actual journalism
there right got in the face of Albert
borla from Pfizer got in the face of
John Kerry and a whole bunch of those
other guys actual journalism it's it's
hard to believe that it still exists but
now C11 is going to make it that much
harder for an outfit like the rebel
which is doing great work to be able to
get their information out there we don't
know what algorithm we don't know what
right now before C11 is put in we
already know that we are screwed at some
level when it comes to the algorithmic
tricks like your ability to even see
this video right now we have no idea
what YouTube is doing to either ensure
that you see it or don't see it I have
no way of directly making sure that
these videos get out to you even if you
subscribe to our videos we know there's
algorith algorithmic manipulation by the
way this is one of the reasons that I
created locals and I'm so thrilled that
the community is growing because you can
always get direct contact with me and I
can always get in direct contact with
you so just quick promo here
reubenreport. look at that
reubenreport.locals.com you don't have
to pay a dime if you don't want you can
if you want to but that way at least we
can make sure everything gets to you but
so we already have big Tech uh
censorship right we already have their
algorithmic tricks and now they are
trying to hardwire that into the system
through the government through this bill
c-11 in Canada and of course this is a
complete uh extension of everything
Justin Trudeau has done you know about
all the authoritarian nonsense but how
do these things happen they don't just
happen overnight Justin Trudeau has been
a politician for a long time and he has
pushed on freedoms and talked about you
know arresting people and finding people
uh if they use the wrong pronoun right
that was Bill c-16 which is really what
put Jordan Peterson on the map in Canada
they will freeze your bank accounts if
you protest them they will make sure
that you can't peaceably peaceably
protest they still will put preachers in
prison in Canada uh if they are not
abiding by their ridiculous laws related
to of vaccines and everything else so it
happens slowly you don't just wake up
one morning and go holy cow The Invasion
is here you can actually see The
Invasion on the horizon this is
something that Jordan Peterson told
Rogan about a couple years ago we've
played this clip a few times but I think
it's perfectly applicable to what's
going on right now yes I just don't
understand how it gets to the point
where things get to terrible places one
tiny step at a time you know if I
encroach if I encroach on you and I'm
sophisticated about it I'm going to
encroach two millimeters I'm going to
encroach right to the point where you
start start to protest then I'm going to
stop then I'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then I'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then I'm going
to stop then I'm going to wait and I'm
just going to do that forever and before
you know it you're going to be back
three miles from where you started and
you'll have done it one step at a time
and then you'll go oh how'd I get here
and the answer was well
I pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then I pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed
and perhaps we've all been agreeing one
way or another or most of us at least
one way or another over these last
couple years that would get us to a
situation like Canada is in right now
but when you talk about that sort of
encroachment on all of this all you have
to do is go back and listen to what
Justin Trudeau has been saying for years
to understand that this was the plan
here is Justin Trudeau 10 years ago and
look who he just admires so much
Kudos meeting last week with a group of
Toronto women was an example even with
sun TV watching for any slip he was
asked which country he most admired and
referred to China there's a level of uh
admiration I actually have for China
um because their basic dictatorship is
allowing them uh to actually turn their
economy around on a dime and say we need
to go green as fast as we need to start
you know investing in solar
how did none of those people sitting
there throw an Apple at him or like some
you know rancid lettuce or something
like I'm the leader of the country and
uh I admire the basic dictatorship the
most and everyone sits there like oh the
basic dictatorship that's wonderful we
love the basic dictatorship so he was
telling the people of Canada what he was
going to become he didn't even have to
hide it which is rather extraordinary
and probably should be something studied
about the way people vote for People
based on things that have nothing to do
with freedom it mostly has to do with
socks and hair something like that but
why do they want to make sure that they
can control the internet in Canada
specifically well Canada was a pretty
docile country right it's not a plate
you don't think of Canada as a war
country or with a lot of internal strife
or racism or all of these things but
then during covid because of his
policies these people who were mostly
like kind of like we're Canadians
there's a lot of room up here there's
not a lot of us it's cold we don't
really fight with everybody they finally
had enough he still to this day Justin
Trudeau has not let go of his emergency
Powers related to covid we know all of
the horrible things that he did but why
does he want control of the internet he
wants control of the internet because it
used to be that in Canada people only
got their news from the CBC as I said
the state funded news organizations but
now because of the internet this thing
with the that Al Gore built with the
pipes and all that because of that thing
people are waking up and they're not
into the vaxes they're not into the
lockdowns they're not into the masks the
mandates or anything else so Trudeau has
to go on TV and scare people about them
because they ain't into him
when you twist the facts or make things
up for political gain
that's not responsible leadership
recent studies show that misinformation
on covet has cost hundreds of millions
of dollars and thousands of lives
peddling misinformation and
disinformation
as serious and devastating consequences
and it's incredible right it's
absolutely incredible that is as my
friend Viva fry says confession through
projection everything he's saying there
could be applied to him not the people
he's actually accusing it of when they
twist facts he twisted facts all the way
down all the way down the line when it
came to covid make things up for
political gain remember when he said
that the reason that the truckers were
out there was because they were racist
white supremacists transphobes they
think that's really why the truckers
were out there and peddling
misinformation I mean this he his
at least from a Canadian perspective
he's the number one misinformation
specialist in the whole freaking Country
Now why is this interesting you might be
watching this going well I'm not
Canadian I don't really care about this
I don't really care about Justin Trudeau
I hope you do but you might say no no
it's not going to happen here whether
I'm in the United States or elsewhere
this is a Canada problem they voted for
that schmuck let them have it well the
problem is
that Justin Trudeau who is a stooge of
the world economic Forum we know that we
know that absolutely clearly he also is
a globalist a globalist is someone who
believes that there should be one
government over all of us one ring to
rule everybody and that he will no
longer be abiding by the laws of his
country he will be abiding by the laws
of this giant monolith that will dictate
to everyone how to live one of the other
organizations besides the world economic
Forum that is very much in line with
that psychotic dystopian ideology is the
United Nations which at one time I don't
know maybe 50 60 years ago was actually
a fairly decent organization that helped
countries kind of come together and put
some sense into the world and give us a
world order that was actually somewhat
decent that has nothing to do with the
United Nations of 2023 and here is the
United Nations Secretary General I
believe this is yesterday and yes he
wants to make sure that they crack down
on you
we'll call for Action from everyone with
influence on the spread of means and
this information on the internet
governments Regulators policy makers
technology companies the media Civil
Society
stop the hate
set up strong guard rails be accountable
for language that causes harm
and as part of my report or common
agenda we are convening all stakeholders
around the code of conduct for
information Integrity on digital
platforms
and will also further strengthen our
focus on our means and this information
are impacting progress on global issues
including the climate crisis
if we had a president who was competent
or remotely pro-america or something
like that I would be a hundred percent a
hundred percent for the president of the
United States to first off kick the
United Nations out of New York City
right we're footing the bill on a whole
bunch of this stuff and there's always
these stories every year about how none
of the ambassadors or any of the people
from other countries they don't pay
their parking tickets in New York City
right uh just as one little small
example of the negligence of these
people but I would have no problem
kicking that guy out of the country that
we foot the bill to have this crazy
giant building where you run rampant
with your anti-western anti-free speech
uh anti-anti decent Society nonsense
where the Human Rights Commission is
usually run by Syria and Lebanon and you
get up there in a place that that
defends Free Speech a country that is
the beacon of free speech in the entire
world and you dare get up there in what
was once a great City not So Much
Anymore New York City and you talk about
how you're going to pressure governments
to step down and clamp down on free
speech that you want more guard rails
you want to watch out for language well
sorry tough guy we've got the first
amendment in the United States and it's
backed up by the Second Amendment and uh
you ain't gonna do it here with the
first amendment is still the jealousy
world over there are many other
countries that unfortunately will abide
by these globalist dictates because they
don't have it's not baked into their
founding their founding documents that
you are allowed to say what you think
and what's also interesting is these big
tech companies that he's trying to apply
this pressure on many of them are
American companies so Elon Musk I am
fairly certain is not going to bend to
this guy's will some of them Facebook
some of the other ones again they're
still American companies but they might
be more inclined to do that Elon Musk
saw that video going around on Twitter
and this is what he responded with the
UN is more likely to cause rather than
prevent disinformation ain't it the
truth so we have some good good people
fighting but why do they want to censor
right like you can you can censor people
there's a certain power in it I don't
like what you say you can't say it but
really why are they censoring why is it
that Justin Trudeau wants to make sure
that Rebel news cannot criticize his
government they want power but but how
do you get power you get power by
controlling the culture that is what so
much of what we talk about here all the
time is about and when you control the
culture and you control information you
can pretty much do whatever you want and
unfortunately we've been letting that
happen even here in the United States
for quite some time this is an oldie but
a goodie it's worth
repeating uh here is Jen saki I have not
shown a video of her in quite some time
this is July of 2021 confirming that the
Biden Administration actually does flag
posts to Facebook for Facebook to
silence you this should have taken down
the entire Administration as a direct
violation of our first amendment whether
it meant that she had to be fired or if
it had been ordered by Joe Biden or
whoever was at the CIA or the FBI
somebody should have been fired nobody
got fired jensaki did get a cushy gig
for a couple million a year over at
MSNBC here's sake
this is a big issue of misinformation
specifically on the pandemic in terms of
actions Alex that we have taken or we're
working to take I should say from the
federal government we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
Facebook that spread this information
we're working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect to Connected
medical experts with popular with
popular who are popular with their
audiences with uh with accurate
information and boost trusted content so
we're helping get trusted content out
there
flagging posts helping certain things be
seen by boosting them Etc et cetera this
should have taken down this sham
Administration right then and there it
was a direct assault on our first
amendment and we all let it happen we
all let it happen it was on us but again
why are they censoring a certain set of
people is it because people like me and
people like you are really
disinformation Specialists are we
misinformation Specialists because we
were skeptical of a vaccine that now it
has become very obvious you should be
skeptical of because we didn't want to
hide in our homes and we didn't want to
sacrifice the Known World on their altar
of quote-unquote science but they're
doing all of this because they want to
control the culture they want to control
the narrow Pathways that we're allowed
to look at the world through and if you
want to see how they want to control the
culture we're going to have to show you
a clip from MSNBC The televised mental
institution this is joy Reed who is a
neo-racist I think she's probably unwell
mentally this is the same woman who
after that shooting in a valde where
that kid shot 18 kids and I think three
teachers her show the next day she led
it by saying that he was not mentally
ill but this was only about guns I mean
this woman is is really really bananas
and I know I say bananas a lot but this
woman is a basket of rancid bananas here
she is talking about how the left is
winning the culture War now note the
Glee she's she expresses this with and
listen to all of the things that she
describes as wins and then you really
think about it if if this what she
describes is the America that you want
to live in the America that your parents
want to live in that your grandparents
maybe came here for and what say I don't
know maybe Dr Martin Luther King Jr was
all about
I hadn't watched in years but I actually
really enjoyed it although I'm not sure
everybody else did it was to put it
mildly a celebration of the very thing
the American right has turned into its
latest anti-wokness Boogeyman diversity
equity and inclusion
the show opened with Puerto Rican singer
Bad Bunny singing 99 in Spanish then
host Trevor Noah walked and talked
through a room that was diversity equity
and inclusion in human form
the first country Americana artist to
perform Brandy Carlisle was introduced
by her wife and daughters we saw the
first trans artist when a Grammy Kim
Petras who has a hit song with Sam Smith
the British singer who came out in 2019
as non-binary black acting Superstar
Viola Davis became an egot winning a
Grammy to add to her Golden Globe Oscar
and Tony Awards lizzo performed with her
amazing choir of many sized singers
the culture wars are over and the left
one like total defeat I can only imagine
the heads exploding in red States I
imagine Ron DeSantis is somewhere
stalking through his Governor's Mansion
trying to figure out how to ban the
Airing of the Grammys in Florida and
take away cbs's tax exemptions no
educational value queer Theory black
music
it's a helpful reminder that despite the
almost hysterical War the right is
waging to take the culture back to the
John Wayne era they are not just losing
they literally cannot win
actually lady you literally cannot win
because of our founding documents you
are a racist what you care about most is
the color of a singer's skin you also
seem to care if they're fat that counts
as diversity you're obsessed with their
racial makeup and their ethnic
background and their sexuality and
whether they chop their genitals off and
you think that's winning it's funny
because you're on MSNBC which basically
nobody is watching anymore it has a
cultural relevance because you've got
NBC behind it so you have one of the
world's largest corporations behind it
but me on this little show that we do
here with my ragtab group of people we
have more people who watch this show on
a daily basis with no budget other than
the one that our subscribers afford US
and whatever we make on ads and we're we
are doing something that is way more
culturally relevant actually you're at
the end of the Rope you're at the end of
the Rope of bad ideas when you literally
want equity you want to count the amount
of black people you have and you want to
count the lesbians and the and
everything else that's what you want to
do and you want to do it in the name of
diversity and everything else but
actually what you hate most is diversity
you hate actually people who think
differently than you I accept that
people think differently of me and I can
make room for them in a country that I
live in but Ron DeSantis is not coming
for the Grammys and not only are your uh
ratings at MSNBC trash but nobody
everyone that watched the Grammys I mean
yes there's this little sliver of people
that watched to enjoy them but basically
everybody watches just the clips so that
they can mock them and when you guys do
your little devil worship with the Trans
guy and the half whatever girl and all
of this stuff you're actually showing
how exasperated and ridiculous your
movement has gotten Grammy viewership
actually on a technical note has been
sinking year over year every year since
2000 and 11. so you tell me how you're
winning Joy Reed tell me about that but
it continues of course on MSNBC uh
Nicole Hannah Jones
uh is one of the much like Joy Reid one
of the race traders that we have in
society today and uh here she is lying
about the AP course and DeSantis and
African-American history and all that
stuff history of Black Americans is so
inconvenient to the mayor The Narrative
of America that there are you know
powerful interests that haven't ever
wanted us to Grapple truthfully that's
why we have Governor DeSantis Banning AP
African-American studies in Florida
that's why we have all these so-called
anti-critical race Theory laws that are
trying to make it more difficult to
teach about racism and to teach about
um what black Americans have experienced
because if you acknowledge that then you
have to acknowledge that we were founded
on these great ideals but we have not
lived up to them there's so much
stupidity in everything they say is an
obfuscation of the truth okay as you
guys know so we don't have to belabray
the point he did not ban an honest
assessment of American History or black
history black history is a part of
American History uh he did not want
critical race Theory which is a
political ideology that is deeply
anti-American and based in equity not
inequality he did not want that being
taught on top of the fact that they had
somehow combined genderqueer Theory into
the AP African-American studies course
so he of course he did the right thing
but everything that these people want is
to undo all of the goodness of America
that's all they want to do and Nicole
Hannah Jones sits there there is no
doubt she has millions of bucks in her
pocket that she got through the 16 19
project which had all sorts of flaws in
it that the New York Times slowly
corrected over a series of time uh this
country the founding principles of this
country were not slavery we fought a war
to end slavery pretty frequent pretty
freaking freaking pretty freaking
quickly in our after our founding uh and
more and more people want to come here
still than any other place on Earth
including her which is why she doesn't
leave she also figured out how to live
in a pretty Swanky condo it looks like
up in the hills somewhere that looks
like maybe it's La uh so she's doing
okay but what they really want to
confuse you about instead of looking for
a positive vision of the future where
say we have equality and people don't
care about skin color and they don't
care about race and gender in any of
those things she wants us just to keep
focusing on that happened 400 years
ago uh but actually it's not even the
that happened 400 years ago it's
the Distortion of reality that she's
focused on from 400 years ago and I
think what we have to decide as
Americans is which country do we want to
be do we want to be the country that
begins in 1619 with the practice of
slavery or do we want to be the country
that was conceived in 1776 with the
ideas of Liberty and equality
um I think that is uh that's unknown I
think we always are seeing the tension
and the fight between these two halves
really bizarre because lady you should
want to be the country that we were that
we are actually except for people like
you that we were founded in 1776 a group
of people who did not want taxation
without representation who wanted
self-rule who created documents that
freed more people in the history of the
world than any other place that people
that we literally it is in our DNA to
take people with nothing and bring them
here so that they have a freaking chance
and we don't have a caste system and
people are allowed to work their way up
and that's why every single one of you
watching this have a better life than
your grandpa parents had and you're
certainly than your great grandparents
and great great grandparents and
everything else and that still is the
reality even today despite everything
that our current Administration is doing
but she wants you to focus on slavery
which of course when when they want you
to focus on slavery and everyone should
learn an honest assessment of slavery
slavery is a horrific blight on the
history of America it's a horrific
blight on the history of many Western
European nations and Eastern European
nations and African nations yes black
people also enslaved black people but
they want to keep you focused on things
that you had nothing to do with so that
they can control your life more now it's
as simple as that because at some point
they want they want to actually break
the idea of America these people
fundamentally do not like Freedom they
don't like the idea that freedom on the
margins is a little bit messy and it
isn't a perfect perfect explanation of
everything and some people using their
own Freedom will live a little
differently than you and that is the
diversity that these people hate more
than they anything else so the other
thing that they're going after is the
idea that the United States is
exceptional and the United States is
exceptional again why does nobody leave
what give me the second best place
give me give me one place that's better
it's a better way to phrase it give me
one place that's better Hannah Nicola
Jones give me one place that's better
AOC and why don't you go there instead
of just complaining what a racist
patriarchy here and wasting so much time
trying to destroy what these old racist
white people created why not go
somewhere else there's got to be
somewhere in Africa you want to go
there's got to be somewhere in Asia that
must be much better I'm sure those Asian
countries aren't racist at all I'm sure
there's no racism against other Asian
people in China or something like that
so they want to destroy the very
Foundation of America which is the idea
that we are exceptional because then you
can put aside all of your nonsense your
skin color and those things and then go
get what you want and that's what they
hate here's Sunny Hosten of The View
the problem that I have is with this
Narrative of American exceptionalism
exceptionalism that we've been taught
since we were kids I mean I I set the
Pledge of Allegiance you know all
through my life in school and then when
I got into college I took an
African-American history course and I
started realizing that the actual Pledge
of Allegiance doesn't apply to a lot of
our citizens well they were including us
yeah it hasn't met the the dream of
being exceptional it hasn't met this
country hasn't met this dream of being
this beacon on a hill and so I think to
the Supreme Court has already ruled you
can't force anyone to take the pledge
but I think until we really meet the the
the
promise of what this country could truly
be then we shouldn't be touting us out
as as exceptionalists Sonny leave I
really mean it leave America go
somewhere else that you think is more
exceptional go somewhere else where you
can accomplish your dreams you're a
Millionaire on television every day who
just rails against the very system that
let you an untalented hack who is not
bright nor interesting nor Pleasant uh
it has allowed you to become super rich
and influential
so maybe there is something wrong with
America come to think of it actually now
that I'm thinking about it a little more
clearly America really did screw up
because it allows people like Sunny
Hosten to become super rich and
influential and everything else uh the
American founding was good the Pledge of
Allegiance is good the ideas and these
documents were aspirational they were
just people of their time who had to
Grapple with slavery and with inequality
and women couldn't vote and all those
things and we've consistently through
time just one after the other knocked
down the barriers that that stopped
people from being equal but there's to
see the other thing that they're doing
here and that that Hannah Nicole Jones
does and that lunatic Joy Reid does and
sunny does is they think that somehow if
you just give them enough power they can
create the perfect state right and it's
like man you guys can't create jack
you can make pretty bad TV shows right
you can spread misinformation you can
spread hate and jealousy big part of its
jealousy that's what you're really good
at so go somewhere else I really mean it
like you can go nobody really wants you
here you guys this is what you believe
in so why why bother there's just so
many white supremacists here why bother
well you know what they might be right
at some level which is that the country
is struggling a bit and we're going to
hear a lot of nonsense tonight from Joe
Biden as he tries to confuse you about
that but it's struggling because of
people like them not despite people like
them it's struggling because there are
people like them out there who would
love for this thing to fail uh here's a
video uh CNN poll saying that a record
number of Americans are financially
worse off under Biden than they were
before this is related to all of this
because this will give these America
haters the Hannah Nicole Jones The Joy
reads and the Sonny hustams this will
give them joy things are not going well
here at the place that they don't like
so that must somehow be a good sign
wouldn't you think and if you look at
this poll are you worse off financially
since the president took office this is
in the Washington Post ABC poll that's
the highest number they've been polling
for 37 years and 41 of Americans say
they're worse off since the president
took office that's the old Ronald Reagan
question right right for election do you
feel better off other than you were four
years ago so that's it so we all know
that the average person is worse off go
to the supermarket and look at the price
of things so if your salary stayed
roughly the same and the price of eggs
is now 8.99 for a dozen or they don't
even have eggs at all or the price of
the couch that you want to buy or the
T-shirt the jacket whatever it might be
if all the prices are going up because
of inflation and your salary is staying
the same then you are losing money so
everyone understands that this inflation
thing is out of control uh well everyone
except one guy there's this one guy who
doesn't really understand it and even as
a job market reaches historic highs
inflation continues to come down
inflation has now fallen for six
straight months gas prices are down more
than a dollar fifty a gallon since their
Peak food inflation is falling as well
as inflation is coming down take-home
pay for workers is going up real wages
are up wages for lower income
middle-income workers have gone up even
more
all right taking blame for inflation no
why not because it was already there
when I got here man remember what the
economy was like when I got here
jobs were hemorrhaging inflation was
Rising we weren't manufacturing a damn
thing here we were in real economic
difficulty
everything that mine muddled buffoon
says is a lie everything he said is a
lie so we've got some info from statista
here between 2010 and 2020 uh inflation
was basically around one to two percent
right so things went up a little bit the
cost of things went up a little bit the
dollar was worth a little bit less in
2021 Joe Biden was on the clock 2021 uh
inflation was 4.7 in 2022 that was just
last year uh inflation
7.7 when he talks about things like gas
prices going down and things like that
it's like yeah because gas prices went
up in such crazy ways that now you say
all right they're down 1.50 but if they
Rose four dollars another down 1.50
they're still up so every and that's
what you have to watch out for for
tonight when you're when you're getting
drunk watching this elderly buffoon
poorly read off the teleprompter you
must understand that every single thing
that they're going to say is going to be
a confusion of reality because it won't
have any context to it things are a
little bit better because we made things
so much worse so it had to get a little
bit better here's Biden economic advisor
Brian deese just repeating meaningless
slogans that Biden tells him and then
the media writes uh the repetitious
nonsense that the two of them spout
well uh on Friday morning when I was
over with the president in this in South
Court he he he said this so I will just
say what he said on Friday which is that
the state of the economy is strong oh
guys the state of the economy so he was
over there and he talked to Joe Biden
and Joe Biden said the state of the
economy is strong and he said it to him
and then he got there and stood in front
of the podium and said it to them and
then the journalists write it because
that guy said it and he heard it from
the other guy so obviously to say to the
economy strong it doesn't matter that
your 401k is going down it doesn't
matter that the market is going down it
doesn't matter that car prices are going
up and that food prices are going up Joe
Biden said it to him and then he walked
over to this other office and then he
said it to a bunch of people this is
what they do with everything here's more
from this decent clown the first is to
put the progress that we have made
economically into back into the broader
frame uh that really compelled him to
run for president in the first place and
the broader frame around what it
actually means to pursue what he refers
to as a bottom out uh middle middle out
bottom out middle out bottom up economic
strategy
just nonsense and Joe Biden does not
believe in a bottom-up economy he
believes in a top-down economy which is
why they love taxes Democrats love taxes
they want to take more of your money and
then occasionally give what was yours
back to you and they go you see what we
did we're such nice people look at us
look at us right what do Democrats do
often right before elections they
suddenly cut taxes right you can see
that Gavin Newsom does this sort of
thing all the time we're going to have a
big tax cut it's like well how about you
just stop taking our money in the first
place but no they can't do that so Joe
Biden the idea that he wants a bottom a
bottom-up economy you'd have low or no
taxes period so that people would have
more of their money so that they could
get out there and they could start small
businesses so they could accomplish
their dreams and they could hire more
people and all of those things if you
were to cut let's say my taxes I could
look at the numbers at the end of the
year I go boy you know the the
government well I don't even have state
income tax here in in Florida so that's
pretty good right so I make more money
by living in a free state which is wild
I did not move here for that but it's
it's an incredible bonus and I do think
and I will say it's a DeSantis we should
start charging an entry tax before more
of these zombies move here but
if you I was to look at the books at the
end of the year and go boy well you know
the the federal income tax is quite high
but it just got half I would have more
money then now could I buy a uh an extra
car I suppose I could we only have one
car as a family here we could use
another car but you know what I might do
I might go you know my guys are working
hard let's hire another person
and then someone else has a job and
their life starts get gets going that
would be bottom up bottom up would be
that you wouldn't have crazy regulations
on everything so that it becomes very
hard to become a hair stylist because
you have to get this license and that
license and everything else or that to
become a house Builder because you have
to have every regulation known to man or
whatever it might be so you're going to
hear a lot of nonsense tonight a lot of
just blatant nonsense but don't worry
guys Corinne Jean-Pierre was asked about
it yesterday and Biden is heavily
involved in what's going to happen
tonight
give this speech tomorrow night well as
you know the president is heavily as
I've said many times heavily engage in
the writing process when you when you
hear the speech you're certainly here
there will be no question that this is a
Joe Biden uh Joe Biden State of the
Union speech so just want to make that
really clear but you know don't want to
get ahead of what you're going to hear
from him
no question guys it's going to be a Joe
Biden speech I do believe Joe Biden will
be the man up there reading it but there
is zero chance there is just zero chance
that Biden will write one freaking line
in this thing and by the way I'm not I'm
not mocking the fact that they have
speech writers of course they have
speech writers but the idea that Joe
Biden is heavily involved yes I'm not
going to say this I am going to say this
it will be a miracle it would be a
miracle if Joe Biden was awake right now
they have to drug him they have to give
him the pills they have to pull his face
back and do whatever else they have to
do with him and then they get up there
and they pray you must understand these
people pray to Satan or whoever they
pray to to just have him get through
that speech without his head exploding
or his eye falling out or his skin
disintegrating like at the end of
Indiana Jones Okay Biden is not writing
this speech unless unless well in the
past he had written some what was it
because yeah
it reappeared in the New York Times with
a new charge that Biden had appropriated
a famous litany from the late Robert
Kennedy about what the gross national
product cannot measure cannot measure
the health of our children the health of
our children the quality of our
education the quality of their education
the joy of their play or the joy of
their play Biden gave Kennedy no credit
he is also quoted or paraphrased John
Kennedy Hubert Humphrey and British
labor party leader Neil kinnick all
without credit Joseph Biden admitted
today that he committed plagiarism when
he was in law school he said it was a
mistake but that it was unintentional he
quoted five pages of someone else's work
without proper citation I've done some
dumb things and I'll do dumb things
again he was given an F ladies and
gentlemen I've been dumb
that should be the line of the
presidency I've done some dumb things
and I'm going to do some dumb things
again oh my God just ridiculous anyway
what's happening right now is that there
is this feeling amongst the Democrat
Party like he got us through the
midterms somehow like he's still alive
whatever but can he run again right
because we this is all gearing up to the
2024 situation and Corrine Champ here
was asked about that because Democrats
are finally starting to question I would
say his mental Acumen is physical health
and just like should they just get rid
of him at this point he served the
purpose he he did what the system needed
him to do and now the system can get rid
of his old bones yeah the majority of
Democrats don't want the president uh to
seek re-election they uh they're looking
for new generation concerns about his
age without getting into whether or not
the president will will announce does
the president believe that he has to
address those concerns from his own
constituents so I'm as you just laid out
I'm going to be very careful covered by
the Hatch Act don't want to get into uh
the specifics of what 2024 is going to
look like or any underlying components
of that the president has been very
clear he intends to run and you know I
think the way that we should look at
this is what we saw from the midterms
just so many words it's just word after
word but they say absolutely nothing but
a girl like her a gal like her she's got
to go down with the ship gay Pete's got
to go down and ship they're all in on
the nonsense so they all have to be in
on the nonsense until the pressure
becomes so much to bear that they can
get off and they will they will gladly
gladly bury Joe Biden in the name of
continuing their careers that is the
beauty of this thing like this does not
end well for Joe Biden but CNN uh was
talking about what's going on with the
election and this is interesting because
they're now showing that a bunch of
people and I look I not that I trust CNN
but here's some some interesting polling
a majority of Americans don't want Trump
or Biden that maybe we're just moving
past the old things
no repeats please that's the message
from voters in a brand new ABC News
Washington Post poll the survey Crystal
Clear take a look broad majorities
Americans simply don't want Donald Trump
or Joe Biden back in the White House
come okay so that's interesting right so
most people don't want Trump don't want
to buy it now look I happen to like
Trump do I like the santis more do I
think that he would be a better standard
Bearer for the ideas I believe in and
that he has he done a bang-up job here
and is surrounded by the right people
and all those things yes I do but I
happen to like Trump and there are many
situations in which I could end up
supporting him and doing everything I
could to make sure that he would be
president and it would be far better
obviously than Joe Biden but the simple
truth is how old is Trump is 78 if I'm
not mistaken and Biden is now 79 or 80
even 81 these guys have to move on there
has never been a generation in Modern
Times Like These Boomers who will not
move on Gen X the people who are
basically somewhere between let's say 35
and probably late 50s I'm right in the
middle of that 46 are supposed to be in
charge right now but for some reason the
Hillary Clinton's and the Nancy Pelosi's
and the Mitch McConnells and the Donald
Trumps and the Joe Biden's and the list
goes on and on they will not get out of
the way I think there's there's
philosophical reasons for that and
existential reasons for that and there's
all sorts of reasons for that it's a
it's a system that caters maybe to
people holding on forever but it is time
to move on you just think about how
fundamentally different the world is now
than it was in say year 2000 23 years
ago right 20 I remember in year 2000 it
was right before 9 11.
that I got my first phone I had a Nokia
little black and white phone that all
you could do is make phone calls and it
had that little not even predictive text
you had to like press the thing the
three times to get a certain letter and
all it did had was snake on it spent a
lot of time playing snake probably a lot
better than what most people are doing
on Tick Tock now
um but that was the world that we lived
in there it was before apps and the
iPhone and internet and algorithms and
all of those things Joe Biden at that
point 23 years ago was 24 years into
politics I think he's been in politics
for 47 48 years now do you think he's
the best person to be running the
country do you think Dianne Feinstein
who also has Alzheimer's and they hide
her and she's 90 something years old
she's going to run again these people
don't stop and why is Nancy Pelosi
running around children the children the
children
these people are scary they have to go
away enough is enough we need new blood
but speaking of New Blood uh one of the
things I've been telling you on on the
positive note and how we can hold the
line on this and actually reverse some
of this stuff is that Republicans are
getting balls the fight that happened
for McCarthy's leadership worked
McCarthy is actually starting to act
strongly he's cutting some of the
funding on some of this stuff that is
one of the things that you can do in
Congress you can basically tighten the
purse and not give the money to
everybody all the time for every idiotic
thing they want to do and of course
we're having this big fight now about
the debt ceiling frankly I would love
for the government to shut down I think
one of the reasons they never shut
they're always threatening to shut down
the government the reason they never do
it is because three days into it a whole
bunch of us would be like ah I don't
need them I don't need them I'll figure
out how to get to a national park I'll
figure out where the bathroom is we'll
figure it out we just don't need them so
here's McCarthy calling out Biden's
nonsense when it comes to the uh the
debt ceiling now President Biden wants
Congress to raise the debt limit yet
again
without a single sensible change to how
government spends your hard-earned money
none
does that sound responsible to you
so you got to understand here that the
outcome of this thing is that they will
raise it again and I I don't like the
idea of the United States defaulting on
its debts if you've ever had a friend
that defaulted amount of debt to you or
you ever didn't pay your credit card and
you hit your max limit like just look at
it that way in your own personal life we
all have a credit card there was a time
where I was in credit card debt I had to
do debt consolidation it screwed up my
my uh my credit score all of that stuff
I had people calling me all the time I'm
debt free now we're good to go because I
did work I stopped spending uh spending
money that I didn't have and I saved
money and did all the right things the
government is allowed to endlessly spend
money and then the Creditor calls up and
goes hey uh uh you know uh Joe could we
get our cash we'd like our cash they go
no no we just want a higher debt Limit
Oh okay we'll just raise your credit
limit you could never operate like that
if you were an individual or a business
but the government is allowed to so what
McCarthy's saying is
in essence what he's subtly saying
without quite saying is look we know
we're raising this thing because this is
what we do right this is just how the
operation works but at least could we
get some concessions on the way could we
get some Cuts here is there any
Department that could be cut could we
get I don't know could we cut catering
at some of our uh Congressional Affairs
could we do that or do we always have to
have lobster we love Lobster but do we
always have to have lobster but what I
think is that the the DC Republicans the
national Republicans they need to focus
on that culture thing more because you
guys know the quote Andrew Breitbart
politics is Downstream from culture if
you get the culture then the politics
Will Change it's not the other way
around and I think McCarthy is getting
it on that as well here's McCarthy on
China and how they are affecting our
culture right now meanwhile China is
infiltrating our culture our farmland
and our skies because they see us as
weak
this is not sustainable no it's not
sustainable they have every kid in
America on a Chinese spy app that we
know about known as Tick Tock they they
floated a Chinese spy balloon over the
United States and we let it happen do
you think that if an American spy
balloon was flying over China today do
you think they'd let it fly over for a
week
what do you think what do you think I
was even thinking about it this way uh
we spent a lot of time in the backyard
here it's Florida it's beautiful I got a
nice pool I got a basketball court we're
always out in the backyard we're playing
with the kids doing all sorts of stuff
out there if my neighbor was flying a
little spy balloon over the house or
even a drone I'm pretty sure I would do
something about it I would either go to
the neighbor's house and demand that
they take it out or I do have a gun at
some point you do something but we need
a group of people in government and in
our cultural apparatus that have spines
and start holding the line I think
McCarthy might be on that path Maybe I'm
Wrong Maybe I'm Wrong maybe the swamp is
that all-encompassing and it's all smoke
and mirrors but but when people start
doing the right thing you got to help
them right the Santa started doing the
right thing in Florida and then it built
on itself like a snowball running
downhill and it kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger how about a snowball
analogy for Florida you got the idea we
have to return to the old ideas that
help create this country that made it
exceptional okay that's what we have to
do it's the reverse of the sunny hostage
it's the reverse of the joy read it's
the reverse of the is it Nicole Hannah
Jones I believe I called her Anna Nicole
Jones who I'm sure is no good too it's
the reverse of Justin Trudeau and with
that in mind allow me to pimp myself out
for just a moment because yesterday we
released a compilation video of all four
of my prageru videos which were shot
over the course of a little over six
years now and and they tell a really
great story about my political Evolution
which I think has obviously been
connected probably to your political
Evolution and there are answers to some
of this stuff so I want to show you just
a moment just a minute of it right now
and we'll link to the full thing down
below which is up on Rumble and YouTube
and locals and everywhere else right
right now I think everything that I've
spent the last couple years talking
about is exactly what is needed in
America right now it's imperfect I'm
imperfect you're imperfect but if we
fight for those ideals and if we act a
little bit more bravely and we turn back
to some of those founding documents that
sometimes seem old and irrelevant I
really think we can fix this thing I'm
Dave Rubin of the Rubin report stealing
these short videos from prageru to shoot
this film
all right so you can get the full thing
right now as I said it's on Rumble it's
on YouTube it's about 25 minutes or so
it's a great I think sort of Voyage of
my own Evolution that is just so
relevant to what is happening here and
it's got the right ideas in it not only
looking back at those documents but
being a little braver say in what you
think things like that so to end the
show today because it is the state of
the union we wanted to give you an old
president you know we like the Reagan
Clips around here and then we realized I
saw this morning today would have been
Ronald Reagan's 112th birthday and I
honestly believe that Ronald Reagan at
112 years old would be more functional
and probably more alive than Joe Biden
so it's a darn shame that Ronald Reagan
won't be given the State of the Union
tonight but here's one uh one of
Reagan's Classics this is this is just
fantastic
someone very profoundly once said many
years ago that if fascism ever comes to
America it'll come in the name of
liberalism and what is fascist fascism
is private ownership private Enterprise
but total government control and
regulation well isn't this the liberal
philosophy the conservative so-called is
the one that says less government get
off my back get out of my pocket and let
me have more control of my own
I think that's going to be a stark
difference to what you hear tonight do
you think do you think all right we got
a post game show coming up at
reubenreport.locals.com the community
continues to grow at a really really
nice rate I hope you'll join us over
there my full interview with Michael
malice which is really blowing up malice
is a great the Willy Wonka of Politics
As I call him just a really great funky
political thinker that's up across
platforms uh we leave you with a cold
close little little humor from The
Gipper and uh
we'll see in 39 seconds
by his very existence and character
Berlin Remains the most compelling
argument for an open world
we're reminded of the many traditions of
openness and democracy that have marked
the history of this city
America missed me
[Applause]
[Music]